wenn sie dieses foto jahre später
betrachten werden sie die sonne auf
ihrem gesicht stören so wie heute
fotograf vom britischen regisseur
du kannst ja eine gute arbeit und findet
auch ein mann
deine großmutter nimmt keine medikamente
mehr weil du nicht heiraten willst du
solltest nächstens heiraten
ein foto die damen
zuckerberg ist sein zweiter film in dem
er im weltkino sich einbringt 2013 hat
welche sparte einen film gemacht der ist
lunchbox der hatte eine vergleichbare
geschichte
damals war die beziehung zwischen einem
mann und einer frau über das ausliefern
von lunch praxis entstanden also auch so
eine zufallsbegegnung oder eine
unwahrscheinliche begegnung in einer
stadt mit so vielen millionen menschen
wenn zwei menschen sich treffen bedarf
es immer eine gewisse magie oder einer
gewissen metaphysik damit daraus etwas
besonderes wird und das besondere ist in
diesem fall eben dass es über die
fotografie läuft das heißt über die art
und weise ihren mann hat eine frau sieht
wie eine frau sich von einem mann
angesehen fühlt sich das ganze dann eben
auch noch verliebter sich das technische
instrument in der truppe kamera und
eines druckers wenn sie dieses foto
jahre später betrachten
werden sie die sonne auf ihrem gesicht
stören so wie heute mit den wind
ernähren haben und alte verstimmen liga
höher
alles wird verschwunden sein für immer
das hat wohl auch mit den schauspielern
zu tun die ganz hervorragend gewählt
sind der dritte sparte hat auch zwei
wichtig dass unsere schauspieler hier
gefunden wie wir gespielt von sawatzki
er schon ein etwas älterer mann das
heißt der als elf millionen auf jeden
fall und als geprägt adressiert könnte
man sagen
durch eine an taktische sanität als ein
mann der als in sich ruht der ganz
zurückhaltend ist und der fast sozusagen
unerreichbar scheint man könnte sich
fast nicht vorstellen dass er jemals
sich zu einer liebesbekundung hinreißen
lässt
aber wie wir wissen so etwas kann eine
figur äußerst attraktiv machen das ist
jeden fall ganz klar so rafi ist mit
seiner passiven oder mit seiner scheuen
präsident tatsächlich so etwas wie ein
magnet in diesem film und da trägt ganz
ganz wesentlich dazu dem ganz starken
duktus bei denn der film ist relativ
ruhig erzählt gibt ganz selten
irgendwelche herausragenden ereignisse
sondern sehr viel spielt sich in der
fast stillen kommunikation zwischen den
beiden hauptfiguren ab wie die sportler
gehörten nicht zu dem indischen kino das
man gemeinhin can dass er das unter dem
unserer schiffe hollywood bekannt ist
bollywood ist ein kino in dem die
gleichen themen verhandelt werden
nämlich die heirats geschichten die
frage wie familien mit der zunehmenden
individualisierung ihrer kinder umgehen
dritte sparte erzählst auf eine andere
weise nämlich in der erzählform die im
weltkino auf festivals oder in dem
bereich der mauthausen ende zwischen
sehr geläufig ist
hast du angst dass sie die einen
stromschlag versetzt jahr und jetzt geht
euch an lächeln bitte da finden wir eine
alters gediegene ästhetische optisch
akustische qualität jetzt besonders dass
anträge aufgefallen alex ran sagte mir
davor nicht hat ein ganz interessantes
ganz stilles thema komponiert das nur
geringfügig die ganze zeit variiert wird
das dem film einen ganz eigenen eigenen
tonfall eben auch gibt ganz fantastisch
sieht man wie gut sie zusammen
mit schokolade vanille
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
der film ist wunderschön fotografiert
also fast schon man könnte sagen fast
schon ein bisschen zu schön
denn von bombay erwartet man ja
eigentlich andere bilder oder es gibt
auch andere bilder aus bombay könnte mir
durchaus vorstellen dass die einen oder
anderen kritiker den finger zu schön
empfinden werden also als ein typisches
arthouse produkt für den weltmarkt das
ist ja auch es ist ein film an dem
internationales geld beteiligt ist auch
deutsches geld auch deutsche produzenten
ein teil der postproduktion wurde in
deutschland gemacht
[Musik]
es ist tatsächlich ein film für den
weltmarkt der aber für meine begriffe
ist reagiert auf die umstände in indien
nicht so sehr auf die sozialen umstände
direkt also das ist jetzt kein
sozialdrama sondern es ist ein film der
sich darauf bezieht wie das indische
kino in seinem populären formen oder in
einem film wie diesen eben mit dem thema
der liebe umgeht und mit dem
unwahrscheinlichen fall dass in einer
stadt mit sehr vielen menschen zwei
aufeinandertreffen die für eine andere
etwas besonderes sind und die wir
einander achten sie freiheit vielleicht
darstellen können
und auf diese weise stellt sich fotograf
für mich als ein film da der mich auf
eine ganz unerwartete weise würde ich
etwas sagen
getroffen hat denn wir waren schon die
ganze zeit klar dass es sich um ein sehr
kalkuliertes produkt auch handelt und
man einen film der ganz genau weiß wie
er das welt publikum ansprechen kam
steht sie sich das für mich als ein
finder die haben wir unerwartet große
freude bereitet hat und den ich
tatsächlich auch zum anschauen empfehlen
würde
wenngleich man immer mitdenken muss dass
das indische kino und auch die indische
soziale situation natürlich deutlich
komplexer ist als diese im kern dann
doch sehr romantische geschichte hier
aber auch eine gewisse beruhige weise
unwiderstehlich ist
er hat das spitzbübische lächeln seines
grossvaters geerbt zeigt es ihnen zeigt
[Gelächter]